when you first start learning how to fly
one of the first things you're going to
notice is that you use your feet to
steer the airplane when you're taxing on
the ground but what should you do with
the Yoke when you're out taxiing around
if you don't hold the controls in the
correct spot and the wind is really
strong it is possible for the wind to
flip you over on your nose or on your
back or on your side and no one wants
that so let's spend a few minutes and
talk about what you should do with a Yol
when you're taxing and strong
[Music]
winds I'm going to to be honest if the
winds are super light and I'm flying a
tricycle gear aircraft I like to just
hold the Yol in a neutral position but
if the winds are really strong then this
is something you want to know how to do
here's the problem the wings of your
airplane are designed to fly in other
words they're specifically designed to
pick up the weight of your airplane and
they don't care if you're ready to fly
or not so if you have enough relative
wind the ax on One of These Wings it
will pick up that wing and flip you over
in a heartbeat so when it's windy you
need to be ready to kill that lift that
could flip you over keep in mind a
headwind is a problem because the wings
can individually create enough lift to
flip you over but if you have a wind
coming from behind you that can be a
problem too because that wind can
actually get underneath one of the Wings
and pick it up very similar to the way
we get a kite to fly because of this a
quartering tail wind is just as likely
to flip you over now the reason I'm
telling you all this is because the way
we handle a quartering headwind is
actually different different than the
way we handle a quartering Tailwind when
we have a quartering headwind we're
trying to kill the lift on the wing
that's creating more lift but when we
have a quartering Tailwind we want to
reduce the amount of wind going under
that upwind Wing so it doesn't get
picked up like a kite okay but how do we
do that and which controls do we use
when taxing in strong winds we have two
tools that we can use to keep ourselves
from getting flipped over the ailerons
and the elevator and both of these are
operated by using either a Yol or a
stick in the cockpit now the good thing
about the ailerons is that because
they're tied together the
decision-making process is really simple
when one Aeron is up the other one is
down and vice versa so all you have to
do is think about that upwind wing for
example let's say we have a quartering
headwind what do we want to do with the
Yoke in this case well with a quartering
headwind we're concerned about this
upwind Wing getting picked up aren't we
so we need to kill the lift on this Wing
how many of you guys remember how an
airplane turns if you don't here's a
quick refresher when we lower an aileron
that Wing creates more lift and the
aileron on the opposite side comes up
which kills the lift on that side this
in turn rolls the airplane so if we have
a quartering headwind from the right do
we want more or less lift on that Wing
we want less lift don't we so in this
case we want to raise that aileron to
kill the lift on that side I know easier
said than done right which way do we
hold the yolk I got a little trick for
you guys position your hands on the yolk
and then and then stick up your thumbs
now remember Thumbs Up ailerons Up
whichever way our thumbs are pointing
that's the aileron that's coming up and
that's the side that we're killing the
lift
on you wouldn't want to get too close to
this guy now I want you to remember this
dumb little joke for two reasons first
it'll help you remember what to do with
those ailerons in a quartering headwind
when you're taxing around on the ground
but this is also the same method you're
going to be using to control the
airplane during crosswind Landings as
well if the wind is pushing me left I
need to point my thumbs into the wind to
kill that extra lift on the right side
your thumb is a killer remember that but
the aerons aren't the only thing we need
to consider we also need to do something
with the elevator as well let's say we
still have a quartering headwind and
it's from the left this time we know
that we need to point our thumbs into
the wind which means our left aileron
should be up killing that lift but what
should we do with the elevator well that
depends on what kind of airplane you're
flying if you're flying an airplane with
conventional gear in other words a tail
dragger like this older tailor craft you
need to hold the yolk back to keep the
tail pinned To The Ground by holding the
yolk back this raises the elevator which
keeps the tail from popping up on you if
you don't do this any wind going over
that tail can cause it to raise up and
that can actually take away your ability
to steer with a tail wheel because your
tail is actually flying instead of being
on the ground but on airplanes with
tricycle gear like a CES 172 or a Piper
Cherokee you want to hold the yolk in a
neutral position and that's because
airplanes like this are designed so that
their nose is a little heavier than the
tail this keeps the airplane flat on the
ground during the takeoff roll which
makes it easier to steer when you're
taxing around that's why nose aircraft
have become popular trainers taxing can
be a little bit tricky in tail draggers
when you're first learning to fly one of
those guys ask me how I know oh stop
stop stop kill the
engine why is
it ah I tried
all
right but what if we have a quartering
Tailwind how should we hold the Yol in
that case as we mentioned earlier a
quartering Tailwind has the ability to
pick up your wing because of the wind
that gets underneath that upwind Wing So
to eliminate wind under the wing we've
got to block it we already know thumbs
up ailerons up so if we point our thumbs
away from a Tailwind this will drop that
upwind aileron which will reduce the
wind going under the wing but there's
one other thing that we need to do with
the ing tailwind and for a Tailwind it
doesn't matter if you're flying a tail
dragger or a trike in both cases you
want to hold the yolk forward this keeps
the elevator down which keeps the wind
from flowing under the tail and picking
it up once again you'll lose steering if
this happens in a tail dragger I'm sure
it's not fun in a trike either unless
you like riding a unicycle gear aircraft
right before you get flipped over on
your nose and speaking of that the FAA
wants you to know that if you're flying
a high-wing aircraft like a CES 172 or a
bc12 D tailor craft it is most critical
that these controls are right when
you're taxing in a quartering tailwind
and that's because those wings are way
up there and they're really prone to
being turned into a
[Music]
kite someone messed up didn't they but
that doesn't mean you have to instead of
spinning $1,000 on a headset that you
don't know for sure you're going to like
try this P1 from core Aviation you won't
mess up and if you decide you don't like
it you can just give it to your
passengers later on but I guarantee you
this is an awesome quality headset and
you're going to love it let's get back
to the training now before I leave you
today I want to go over a few different
ways that the FAA could ask you about
this on the written exam because even
though you know how to do it now they're
going to try to trip you up with stupid
looking questions pictures or diagrams
let's say we have a right quartering
headwind like you see here how should we
position the controls when we're taxing
in a tricycle gear aircraft well we know
that we have a headwind so we need to
kill the lift on that upwind Wing So
Point your thumbs into the wind to raise
that upwind Aeron now what do we do with
the elevator well we're in a tri so
neutral elevator is the best in that
case what if this was a tail dragger the
ailerons would stay the same but we'd
need to pin the tail wouldn't we what
about a left quartering headwind now
what that's right kill that lift with
your thumbs and neutralize the elevator
on a trike but what's going to happen if
you keep the El elevator neutral and a
tail dragger in this situation yeah the
tail could start flying before you're
ready couldn't it next we have a quarter
in Tailwind from the left now what do we
do well we want to lower that upwind
aileron don't we that's going to keep
that wind from moving underneath that
upwind Wing So thumbs up aileron's up
let's Point our yolk over to the right
to drop that upwind Aeron and what do we
do with that elevator yep we want to
push it full forward on all airplanes
don't we some people will tell you that
you want to die away from a quartering
tailwind and that's a really good memory
aid if you're into those so what do you
think we should do if we have a
quartering Tailwind from the right and
you're in a tail dragger then yep we
want to dive away from that wind with
the ailerons and push that Yol all the
way forward and once again an aircraft
with tricycle gear is the same we want
to dive away with the Yol all the way
forward to keep us from getting flipped
over onto our nose and now you know how
to hold the Yol or the stick when you're
out taxing in strong winds and if You'
watched all my other videos and this one
you are now ready to take the FAA
written exam but before you can go do
that the FAA wants to make sure that
you're ready to take the test so because
of that you've got to have an
endorsement from a certified flight
instructor or a ground instructor and as
of today I'm releasing what might be the
cheapest way to get that endorsement if
you'll go to free pilot training. net
you'll find my premium Private Pilot
ground course for only 50 bucks and that
course uses my videos along with quizzes
and tests to make sure that you're ready
for that written test
and when you are ready I'm going to send
you an email with that written
endorsement thank you guys for watching
and I'll see you in the next one see you